okay I'm ready to bring it in advance
streaks into the lane going with a
right-hand scoop up under shingoon
without their two best shot creators
from the perimeter
James steps back and buries a three over
Jabari Smith yeah he's looking at this
situation now how does Sarah little was
looking at the Sacramento Kings game
okay so what the best shot creators on
our roster is out I'm gonna get
something done it was a fun evening
really fun evening fans are really
engaging
always
it's really open with them
very accessible
all the time the fans had a great time
taking pictures with various individuals
here's Dame out way outside go get it
see Jabari Smith Jr on that one Grant
with it out on topped a little over it
comes to Dane elevates for three that's
a deep one and he reeled it in oh man
which is a career high if they want to
stop him I think what they're going to
have to eventually do
Garfield High School in Seattle game
double team spins between Defenders into
the lane he Motors right to the rack and
laid it up and in and this is what he
has been doing particularly well getting
to the line
recovered by a little
Eason will give Dame to Christopher and
Christopher on his heels as Dave sees
that and goes to work
you gotta score
trying to power up on a tip Jam as
Martin Jr couldn't quite secure it
Blazers the other way on the
reverberation it's Dame into the lane
spinning on a reverse up and it tucked
it in
Newman tonight He's listed at 226 he's
every bit of that
name off the screen leads into a triple
got it see like that that's what I'm
talking about
50. now he's got to finish the job
though
reddish for Watford Muller sets his feet
leans back a three got it Damien Leonard
seven threes on the night and 10
attempts he has 36.
pulling this one Dave kept moving Nick's
president did a good time until Dane
game the ball up and now
on the attack missed that one right at
The Rim radish the other way damn a deep
one buried it Damien Leonard from long
range
out in the deep water the defense was
scattered he kept looming that's it
opens back
and this is just too late of a pickup
point from the rocks with experience and
you learn like no things are very
different when he's out there Dave
streaks to the cup and scores on the
scoop tari Eason
Miller going to work because you have to
score in the quarter drives into the
lane going to Lefty over the traffic and
laid it in beautifully
pops out comes off the screen shooting
for three drilled it
Willard with seven here in the quarter
48 for the game gets it back from
Watford
steps back tuck mid-range got it from
three-point range and had nine of his 50
points in the third
off the screen to three Damian Lillard
knocks down a triple Lillard with his
10th three-pointer of the ninth keeps it
to the side rapidly between the
wickets drives inside outside the grant
fakes Hanks finds Dave step back three
powered it up and in with Milling his
arms glaciers by 10 a burst into the
lane
[Applause]
on the boulevard with a right hand jam
and the foul he's leading the Blazers
right down the middle
this is
Give It Up to get it back pin down from
trending comes off the screen
Tate with him sets his feet leans back
for three guys Damien Leonard a career
high the three-pointer for Lillard is
12th of the night
64 points for Damian Lillard in 35
minutes and the crowd is on their feet
the age of 32. one of the great scores
one of the great Shooters of all time
[Music]
knocked it down
gives it back to Grant Dave will Sprint
out on the sideline to get the Rock
High dribble into the lane running
right-hander up and in Damian Lillard
with that Runner
71 points a career high